let's see if we can apply what we know
about negative number what we know about
negative numbers and we would know about
exponents to apply exponents to negative
numbers
so let's first think about let's just
let's say we have negative three
let's first think about what it means to
raise it to the first power
well that literally means just taking a
negative three just taking a negative
three and there's nothing left to
multiply it with so this is just going
to be equal to
negative three
now what happens if we were to take a
negative three and we were to raise it
to the second power
well that's equivalent to taking two
negative threes so a negative three and
a negative three
and then multiplying them together and
then multiplying them together and
what's that going to be
well a negative times a negative is a
positive so that is going to be
positive 9. let me write this is going
to be positive 9.
but let's keep going let's see if
there's some type of a pattern here
let's take negative three
and raise it to the third power to the
third power what is this going to be
equal to
well we're gonna take three negative
threes
one
two
and three and we're gonna multiply them
together so we're gonna multiply them
together negative three times negative
three we already figured out is positive
nine but positive nine times negative
three well that's negative that's
negative 27 and so you might notice a
pattern here whenever we raised whenever
we raised a negative base
so we raise a negative base to an
exponent if we raise it to an odd
exponent to an odd exponent we are going
to get
we are going to get
a
negative
negative value and that's because when
you multiply an even number of times the
negatives a negative times a negative is
a positive and then you have one more
negative to multiply it by which makes
it negative and if you take a negative
base
and you raise it to an even power
and you raise it to an even power that's
because you're always if you multiply a
negative times a negative you're going
to get a positive and then you're doing
so when you do it an even number of
times you're doing a multiple of two
number of times so the negatives and the
negatives all cancel out i guess you
could say or they when you take the
product of the two negatives you keep
getting positives so this is going to be
this right over here is going to give
you
a positive value so there's really
nothing new about multiplying or taking
powers of negative numbers it's really
the same idea and you just really have
to remember that a negative times a
negative is a positive and a negative
times a positive is a negative which we
already learned from multiplying
negative numbers now there's one other
thing that i want to clarify because
sometimes there might be ambiguity if
someone writes
let's say someone writes this
let's say someone writes that i
encourage you to actually pause your the
video and think about what this right
over here would evaluate to
if you've given a go with that think
about whether this should mean something
different
than
that
well this one can be a little bit
ambiguous and if people are strict about
order of operations you should really be
thinking about the exponent before you
multiply by this negative one you could
this is implicitly saying negative one
times two to the third power so many
times this will usually be interpreted
as negative two to the third power which
is equal to negative eight while this is
going to be interpreted as negative two
to the third power now that also is
equal to negative eight and you might
say well what's what's the big deal here
well what if this was what if these were
even exponents so what if someone had
give myself some more space here
what if someone had
these two expressions negative 4 or a
negative 4 squared or
negative 4 squared
this one clearly evaluates to 16
positive 16. it's a negative 4 times a
negative 4. this one could be
interpreted as especially if you look at
order of operations and you do your
exponent first this would be interpreted
as negative 4 times 4 which would be
negative 16. so it's really important to
think about this properly and if you
want to write the number nega if you
want the base to be negative 4 put
parentheses around it and then write the
exponent